In my last video we performed an experiment
in which two identical wood blocks were shot
with the same rifle, one through the center
of mass and the other one slightly off to
one side.
Now if you haven’t seen that video yet,
then click here now and go and watch it.
Or, if you are on a mobile device, click the
link in the description.
So the question was: Compared to the block
shot straight through its center, how high
would the block shot to one side go?
Now 60 percent of you predicted that it wouldn’t
go as high.
>> It didn’t seem as high.
>> Now check out the high speed footage.
>> Oh, no.
>> You can clearly see that both blocks...
>> What?
>> ... go to the exact same height.
>> Oh, come on.
>> Nineteen percent said that it would go
higher.
And only 21 percent correctly predicted that
both blocks would go to the exact same height.
So most of us got it wrong the first time
around and that includes Henry and me and
Destin who has a lot of experience with this
stuff.
>> I mean, I can’t tell you how many times
I have hit wood with a rifle.
>> So even experienced and intelligent people
get it wrong sometimes.
In this case I think the result was particularly
counter intuitive, because the spinning block
clearly ended up with more energy than the
other block.
So I asked you guys to make me a video response
and explain what is happening.
And this is what I received.
>> If you imagine the bullet traveling through
the center of the block, then...
[multiple voices]
>> Whoa.
That is a lot of video responses.
And that is not even all of them.
I have got to say I was blown away by all
of the great video responses I received.
You guys are awesome and really, really appreciate
all the effort you went to.
You know, some of you actually replicated
the experiment, perhaps with different setups.
>> Oh, ah.
>> The experiment was featured on blog posts,
including Scientific America and Wired.
There is an interactive simulation you can
try.
Link is in the description.
And someone even made a web comic.
It is so incredible, you know, watching all
of those video responses.
And I did watch all of them.
That was my proudest moment making this YouTube
channel, seeing all of you guys doing science
and getting so involved and putting in so
much effort.
It just blows my mind.
It is amazing.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you.
I can’t even put it into words how awesome
it is.
Whoo.
So what is the answer?
How could two identical blocks shot with the
same rifle end up with different amounts of
energy?
Well, some of you felt that the amount of
rotational energy would be basically insignificant.
>> What if the amount of energy necessary
to get that very small block rotating really
is negligible in comparison to the amount
of energy necessary to lift it into the air
and resist gravity?
>> Well, we can calculate it, because the
spinning block was rotating at about 11 times
per second.
So you can calculate that its rotational energy
would be equal to 50 percent of the gravitational
potential energy when those blocks were at
their peak.
So the spinning block actually had 1.5 times
the energy of the non-rotating block.
And in my books that is not negligible.
So what else could be causing this?
Well, some of you actually measured the height
difference using pixel counters and found
that the blocks didn't go to exactly the same
height.
So this raises an important question, which
is: How different would those heights have
to be before you can think that there really
is a difference there?
Well, given that the rotational energy is
about 50 percent of the gravitational potential
energy, you might expect the spinning block
to go half as high.
But looking at the video footage you can clearly
see it doesn’t go half as high.
It goes basically to the same height.
To know for sure, you would probably want
to do the experiment a number of times.
In science you have got to repeat things and
make sure what you saw is not just a fluke,
that it will happen every time.
So, in fact, we did repeat the experiment
a number of times and here are all of the
blocks lined up side by side so you can compare
their heights.
The blocks clearly do not all go to the same
height.
So you might say: Derek, you were tricking
us.
You just picked the two that went the closest
and used those.
It is true.
I did do that.
But the point is do the spinning blocks go
systematically to a lower height than the
non-spinning blocks?
And I think from the video footage the answer
is clearly no.
So why not?
Well, another common response I saw was that
air resistance must play a role, that the
spinning block exposes a small surface area
as it is traveling upwards and this means
there is less air resistance impeding it.
So even with a lower velocity it could make
it to the same height as the non-spinning
block.
But you can do the calculation and find that
the difference in air resistance would be,
at most, about 0.6 percent of the weight of
the block.
In other words, negligible.
So what is the real answer?
Well, there are a number of ways of approaching
the problem and I saw you guys try almost
all of them: force, torque, momentum, energy.
But the easiest one of these is the law of
conservation of momentum.
You see, when the bullet is fired out of the
rifle it has a certain amount of momentum
entirely in the vertical direction.
And when the bullet becomes lodged in the
block the bullet and block together must have
that same momentum that the bullet had.
Now it doesn’t matter where on the block
the bullet hits, because the bullet had a
certain momentum before it hit the block.
The block and bullet together afterwards must
have that amount of momentum upwards.
So this means regardless of whether the block
is spinning or not, it must have the same
upwards velocity, so that it has the same
momentum, so it will got the same height regardless
of whether it is spinning or not.
It is simple conservation of momentum.
Momentum is always, always conserved.
It is something you can always rely on.
And it is why you should think about it first.
But some of you may say: Ok, well, there is
also angular momentum in the spinning block.
But the point is: Angular moment and linear
momentum are independent and they are conserved
independently.
So you can simply think about the upward momentum
of the bullet and that is going to have to
be the upward momentum of those two blocks
and it doesn’t matter that one is spinning,
because they have the same total linear momentum
upwards.
So they have to go to the same height.
But if that is the case, why does the spinning
block end up with this extra rotational energy?
Well, the thing about energy is it is a little
bit tricky.
Although total energy is conserved, the energy
of motion—which is called kinetic energy—is
not conserved.
So what happens is as the bullet strikes the
wood a lot of its kinetic energy is lost,
heating up the wood, creating sound and deforming
that wood block.
So it would be possible for the rotating block
to end up with more energy of motion, more
kinetic energy, if the bullet loses less energy
deforming the wood and heating it up and creating
that sound.
And this kind of makes a little bit of intuitive
sense, because if you imagine the bullet entering
the block on the side, the block will be moving
away from it faster, because it is rotating.
So that may mean that the bullet doesn’t
penetrate in as far and so it wouldn’t lose
as much energy as it is entering the wood,
which explains why the block has extra energy
allowing it to rotate and go the same height
as the other block.
Let’s have a look at how far in the bullet
went into each block.
This is our first test.
Here we go.
This is the one where it went straight in.
>> There.
>> Yeah.
>> And we come over here to the opposite end.
>> This is where the bullet went in off center.
>> It is not going in here.
See where my...?
>> Yeah, let’s see the other one.
>> Ok.
It is all the way in.
It is part way in.
>> So the bullet didn’t go as far into the
spinning block.
>> Right.
>> So that was pretty convincing evidence.
But just to be extra sure we x-rayed both
blocks and this is what we saw.
I am going to overlay the blocks so we can
see the difference in penetration depth.
Hang on.
It looks like both blocks penetrated each
block to the same depth.
So does that mean our theory is wrong?
Well, let’s think about how different the
bullet depths should be.
I mean, when the bullet strikes the block
it actually loses 97 percent of its original
kinetic energy.
And the amount of rotational energy the spinning
block has only works out to about one percent
of the original kinetic energy of the bullet.
So we would only expect a difference in depths
of about one percent.
And for our measurements, that would be about
a tenth of a millimeter.
That would be immeasurable and that is what
we see.
So although this answer is a little bit unsatisfying,
at least it is the truth.
As an extra challenge, I want you guys to
think about how we could perhaps modify this
experiment so the difference in bullet depth
would be measurable.
You can leave your answers in the comments
or make me another video response, because
I love those so much.
This episode of Veritasium was brought to
you by Audible.com, a leading provider of
audio books with over 100,000 titles in all
different types of literature.
Now today I wanted to recommend a book that
changed my life.
It is called The Four Hour Work Week and it
is by Tim Faris who I actually got to meet
this year at VidCon.
So I read this book about three years ago
when I was thinking about quitting my job
and starting this YouTube channel.
And it is one of the things that contributed
to my decision.
So if you are thinking about quitting your
job, perhaps this is the book for you.
You can actually download it for free by going
to Audible.com/Veritasium, click the link
in the description or you can choose any other
book of your choosing for a one month free
trial.
So thanks to Audible for supporting Veritasium
and thanks to you for watching.